you use Amazon's doorbell ring or Alexa
listen up Amazon has agreed to pay more
than 30 million dollars to settle
complaints involving these two products
the FTC accused Amazon of allowing
employees to access ring customers
private videos exposing them to hackers
according to the complaint one ring
employee viewed thousands of video
recordings that may have surveyed
bedrooms and other intimate spaces in
the homes of female customers the FTC
also accused Amazon of violating a child
Privacy Law and deceiving parents by
keeping kids voice and location data
recorded by Alexa Amazon said it
disagreed with the ftc's claims but the
settlements quote put these matters
behind us